- I would come into church
and preach that God loves me.
That God accepts everybody.
And I didn't believe that for myself.
I was walking around wearing a mask.
I'm Reverend Derek Terry,
pastor Saint Peter's UCC.
And I am a Black gay man minister.
So, for a lot of people, the idea of being
Black, gay, and Christian
are three intersectionalities
that cannot come together.
I was 19 when I accepted my call to preach
in the African Methodist Episcopal Church.
I was the fifth generation
of my family at this church.
And its bylaws says you can't
ordain someone who's gay
as a minister.
You can't attend, perform,
or condone gay marriage.
I knew that there was not a place for me.
I didn't want that life.
I didn't want the sneaking, the hiding,
the seediness of not
being able to be accepted
for who I was, as I was.
I resigned.
(piano)
When I resigned, I found
the United Church of Christ.
Until today, the idea
that we're looking at
is that I am good enough.
When I first applied to be
the pastor of the church,
I was very nervous, and I didn't think that
they would hire me.
And I said I'm gay, I'm young, I'm Black.
And they said, "Okay."
It is extremely liberating
to be able to come to church,
to be able to stand before people,
and to be loved and affirmed
for who I am, as I am.
Without hesitation, without fear,
and knowing that it
simultaneously empowers others
to do the same.